hello everyone and welcome to a
beautiful game that just happened in the
European Paris Blitz tournament it is
Sean sargassian 21 year old Armenian
Grandmaster versus Yang shisht of Duda
and as the title suggests a queen
sacrifice
um is being used to crush the London
system now uh if some of you have seen
my tutorial on how to defeat the London
system I suggested um uh for black to go
for Knight to F6 C5 in the immediate
Queen to B6 uh Duda throws in an
additional D5 Knight to C6 and then goes
Queen to B6 and then uh goes after the
B2 pawn and for those of you who have
seen my tutorial on how to play against
the London system you know that
sometimes it's okay to grab the B2 Pawn
sometimes it most certainly is not okay
to grab the B2 pawn and here the B2 Pawn
will be captured now let's see what
happened here and why this is so
incredible and the one of the problems
for uh saxyan is that young shisto has
already played this exact same game up
to a certain point two years ago but
we're gonna discuss that when we reach
it so Pawn to D4 we have Knight to F6
Knight to F3 and D5 now we have Bishop
to F4 opting for the London system and
only Now Pawn to C5 with E3 Knight to C6
Knight beat the D2 and normally now
Queen to B6 so going after the B2 pawn
and as usual white very happily offers
the pawn D captures on C5 now either
invites the queen to captran C5 or you
go after the B2 Pawn like you've
prepared so do the captors that Queen
captures on B2 Rook to B1 and now Queen
to C3 you could even capture the pawn
but the engine says Queen C3 is the best
move and so everyone plays Queen to C3
here uh Bishop to B5 and now Pawn to G6
preparing Bishop to G7 castles King side
and so on we have Pawn to E4 and now D
captures on e4 with Bishop to E5
attacking the queen and queen to A5 and
here we have castles offering the Knight
on F3 but as you'll see it's not that
easy to keep the material we have e
captures on F3 by do that remember this
is all still Theory Queen captures on F3
and now how do you continue
uh you've given up a piece but Bishop
captures on C6 is a is a pretty big
problem point is that okay if black
really wants black can continue just
developing Bishop G7 then you capture on
C6 but you can't capture back this is
the piece you've uh given back because
you're already up a piece you have to
play King to f8 and after Bishop
captures on B7 Bishop captures like
Queen captures attack the road The Rook
must the E8 and now Knight to B3 let's
say attacks the queen queen captures on
80 and pawn to C6 uh it's whatever you
can survive against this past C Pawn I
mean even if you can you're just gonna
suffer for for a very long time so
instead do the place Queen captures and
B5 a beautiful queen offering you've
already uh captured one piece so now you
capture another one for the price of a
queen uh and how do you reply to this if
the queen is captured then you grab the
third piece knight captures an E5 so
yeah maybe there's a better way first
instead of this uh Bishop captures on F6
you don't wanna you don't want this
version of the remain a Target on E5 and
now the problem is if you just move the
queen let's say queen to A5 now comes
okay you want to capture the Knight
first Knight will come to B3 attack the
queen and only when the queen moves the
bishop captures on h8 and uh well either
black is lost or maybe black can hold
this with a more like F6 uh so instead
after Bishop captures an F6 Luda now
forces at the trade or rather the the
queen sacrifice Queen captures an F1
with check and okay you have to capture
and this is uh where we we reach the
point that dude already had two years
ago in the 23rd European Team
Championship but his opponent uh
played King captures on F1 here we have
Rook captures on F1 and it is now as of
move 14 that we have a completely new
game so e captures on F6 Queen captures
attacks dude as rook and h8 and now Rook
to G8 we have Rook to E1 with check and
it seems like dude is in a pretty bad
spot but just Bishop to A7 not a problem
we have Knights the C4 now surely do is
completely lost the Knight is coming to
D6 then Queen captures an F7 uh nope
dude that just please King to f8 and now
Bishop capture Sun F6 becomes a threat
the bishop is no longer pinned so here
Queen to F4 and now King to G7
uh we have Rook captures on E7 uh here
you could continue with knights the D6
probably it's objectively best and then
if okay you capture which you probably
will you don't want this um here uh Pawn
to be under attack and if you play
Bishop D6 then also the B7 Pawn hang so
probably something like this and then
maybe if white can get a defended pass
Pawn on D6 maybe white can play this but
black can always undermine it with B6 it
doesn't look all that promising so
instead after King G7 Rook captures an
E7 by shunt and now uh Knight captures
an E7 we have Queen to E5 with checked
now the King has to go back to a fate
Defender Knight but now the Rook is
still out of the game so Duda has to
solve this problem how to get his pieces
into the game with Queen to D6 now
pinning the Knight as well Bishop to E6
and now Knight to A5 going after the B7
Pawn but just Bishop to D5 and it's not
that easy to to figure out how to go
about this with Pawn to H4 akirashan
says if he can get his Pawn all the way
to H6 Maybe can uh you know store some
trouble here on the king side but just
uh Pawn to B6 we have Pawn to C4 now
uh challenges the bishop still hopes uh
to get the pawn all the way to C7 to
create a pass Pawn uh but now Duda plays
Bishop captures and G2 we have King
captures B captures on A5 and now Pawn
to C6 the pass Pawn has been created uh
but the question remains even if you
continue pushing the pawn how is the
pawn ever to reach the C8 Square that's
that's a pretty big big problem uh one
thing okay maybe yeah I mean it's just
impossible uh the the king for the
moment cannot move uh but after Rook to
E8 King to G7 is now prepared the Knight
is defended and your Rooks will connect
we have Pawn to C7 but now King to G7
and the problem is uh there's never any
realistic hope of that pawn ever
reaching that C8 Square so this is not
white pushing for a win because white is
up a queen no not at all white is down
with material two Rooks and the Knight
are much better than a queen okay why
does have the pass Pawn on the seventh
rank but I mean how are you touching the
C8 square like we said so Queen into D4
check
uh Pawn to F6 dude I cannot allow any
any perpetuals to be even in the
discussion we have Queen captures on A7
and now Knight to C8 blocking the pawn
attacking the queen queen captures on A5
and now just Rook Gita f8 and now the
plan is of course put the Rook on the
seventh rank or maybe both of them
capture the pawn and that's pretty much
all of White's counter play uh just gone
so Pawn to A4 uh here ashant continues
uh with his Advance he pushes the past a
pawn Rook to E7 and now Queen to C5 uh
we have Rook after F7 no need to rush
anything let's just prepare the capture
Pawn the A5 and The Rook captures on C7
we have Queen to D5 Rook after D7 and
queen to E6 now comes Rook to E7 uh we
repeat once Rook after D7 Queen to E6
but of course Duda will not repeat Rook
to D6 completely controls now uh all of
the squares we have Queen to E4 and now
Pawn to H5 not allowing uh Sean to
create any uh problems for him on the
Kings side with Pawn to C5 and just Rook
D to C6 here the idea behind this Pawn
offering is that if you capture you can
maybe Queen to B7 with check and now
after the king moves and now Pawn to A6
and it's still black it's completely
winning here but only if you play Rook
to B6 any other move and white will be
able to draw so that's um probably the
attempt here Rook D to C6 was played
with Queen to E3 but not just the Rook
captures on C5 do the leaves no options
open for uh for Sean uh Pawn to A6 and
now just The Rook 5 to C6 with Queen to
F4 now of course if you capture you you
blunder The Rook on C7 but just Rook to
A7 we have Queen to B4 uh and now Rook C
captures an A6 no chondra play here
Queen C4 we have Knights the E7 Queen to
D4 and not Knight to F5 and he was in
this position animal 45 that Ashan
sarcian resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so he's uh down uh okay sometimes maybe
the queen can fight the two Rooks if you
have uh you know a safe King and maybe
you have a you have a pass Pawn that you
can push uh but here against two Rooks
in the Knight and also being down upon
this is of course completely unplayable
and now there is uh no chance for Duda
even to mess anything up so here he just
resigned the game now yeah it's a pretty
incredible and you always have to be
very very careful in these lines of the
London system like I've shown in my uh
in my tutorial when the queen goes after
the B2 Pawn uh I I played in Blitz but
you know sometimes my queen gets trapped
sometimes I you know get out safely and
then I'm just completely winning uh here
if you if you guys enjoy playing with
your queen and B6 also a line that you
you should know it is possible to you
know sacrifice some material give up
your queen even and uh you know have a
have an excellent game I do that already
has proven it twice okay first he got a
draw two years ago but now a beautiful
win so hope you hope you enjoyed that uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it always uh enjoyable when
someone crushes the the London system uh
uh and that move is very happy to show
it I would like to thank Andre
luchnikovkovitzma Brian Baker and Dan
McCormick for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon uh
continuing to check up on this um
wonderful tournament as we also have the
women's section and there uh there's
been quite a showing there as well so we
are going to check that out next uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day